i had been baptized but i keep on
sinning
you keep on sinning yeah like drinking
because
as he i don't know if he's a boy or a
girl but all right
he feels so high socially high with
somebody else who are drinking
that's why he could not resist the act
of
that sin so i've been baptized i keep
drinking and
whatever else all right baptism
is an outward symbol of death
to a past life notice i said death not a
coma
you know what a coma is you know what
unconsciousness is
a lot of people are baptized in a state
of unconsciousness
not death you must be dead
to your past life that's why you are
buried are you with me the life must be
given
entirely to god
when that happens god accepts that life
as his own
and he has the legal right to work in
your life
many of us we surrender ourselves to god
partially
going down in a baptismal pool getting
wet
does not change your life it is the
change that occurs in your heart
and so for this person if you're still
drinking and smoking and whatever you're
doing
you need to re-examine your surrender to
god
you read the new testament jesus said
thou shalt love the lord thy god
with all thy heart with all thy soul
with all thy mind with all thy strength
with all thy might you also find it in
deuteronomy 6 verse
46 it must be total surrender
now even with a total surrender
you are growing and you will slip but
sin will not be a lifestyle if sin is
still
a lifestyle you have to review was
i truly surrendered to god because the
bible says
all things are passed away all things
are become
new